[Musique]
c'est le rendez-vous des plus grands
coureurs automobiles au monde l'histoire
du Grand Prix du Canada remonte à 1967
au parc moschporn en Ontario au cours
des quatre années suivantes le Grand
Prix se tient en alternance entre
mosfort et le circuit Saint-Jovite à
Mont-Tremblant le Grand Prix du Canada
qui était présenté pour la première fois
au Circuit Mont-Tremblant
un circuit apprécié malgré un bon nombre
de courbes
[Musique]
il peut dangereux dans le sens que on
décolle pas mal moi personnellement
j'aime beaucoup le cap mais tous sont
conscients qu'il s'agit d'un sport à
haut risque avec son flegme britannique
il a accueillir les débris et évaluer
les dégâts de la Ferrari de son plus
proche rival finalement de 1971 à 1977
le Grand Prix du Canada se déroule à mon
sport
mais le circuit ontarien est jugé trop
dangereux pour les pilotes et il est
abandonné
l'idée d'un Grand Prix du Canada
Montréal fait alors surface
d'administration municipale propose de
construire une piste dans l'île
Notre-Dame le projet est approuvé en
juin 1978 et la construction du circuit
se réalise en trois mois seulement
[Musique]
le 8 octobre 1978 les amateurs de course
assistent au premier Grand Prix de
Montréal par une journée très froide
d'automne
mais la foule évite réchauffée par la
victoire de Gilles Villeneuve
[Musique]
un Québécois de Berthierville qui
remporte sa première course en Formule 1
en carrière devant plus de 72000
spectateurs un véritable délire s'empare
de l'île Notre-Dame
mais le 8 mai 1982 Gilles Villeneuve se
tue lors des essais du Grand Prix de
Belgique directeur technique d'écuries
mécanicien et pilotes lui vous est une
estime incroyable dotée d'un caractère
énorme d'un talent encore inexploité il
avait su imposer le respect la piste de
l'île Notre-Dame est alors rebaptisée
circuit Gilles Villeneuve en son honneur
et l'épreuve est déplacée de l'automne
au printemps on l'attendait depuis des
jours ce départ et l'antenne avec à ses
côtés Jacques Villeneuve entreprise en
1996 Villeneuve fils le jeune Jacques
Villeneuve termine sa première course à
Montréal en deuxième position les
gradins remplis à pleine capacité et des
admirateurs qui rêvaient d'une victoire
de Jacques Villeneuve sur son plus
proche rival le Championnat du Monde
Michael Schumacher mais au deuxième tour
Jacques Villeneuve a commis
l'irréparable et frappé le mur l'année
suivante malgré sa collision avec le
fameux mur du Québec il devient champion
du monde de F1
mais ce mur n'a pas fini de hanter les
coureurs en 1999 trois champions du
monde Michael Schumacher
et Jacques Villeneuve abandonne en
course après avoir percuté le mur
bienvenue au Québec en 2009 le Grand
Prix du Canada est annulé le grand
patron de la Formule 1 Burny ecole Stone
justifie cette décision par des sommes
impayées depuis trois ans de la part de
promoteurs locaux représenté par Normand
LEGO
[Applaudissements]
mais après le versement d'une somme de
75 millions de dollars d'Ottawa et de
Québec le Grand Prix du Canada à
Montréal revient en 2010 à la grande
joie des amateurs
ensuite rien arrêtera les bolide sur le
circuit Gilles Villeneuve
[Musique]
sauf qu'en 2020 et l'année suivante le
Grand Prix frappe son mur à son tour la
pandémie oblige il doit être annulé
l'épreuve est de retour depuis 2022 avec
en moyenne 200000 spectateurs à chaque
année le Grand Prix du Canada de Formule
1 est l'événement touristique le plus
important au pays
ici Jacques bissonner Radio-Canada
Montréal
[Musique]